i want to share a
quick video here uh i heard on the radio
you guys know that i uh have shared
these ghosting segments before
um
some of you guys are a little
offside and you think they're fake i'm
gonna show you one that
it's not fake and all the ones that i've
posted in the past are not fake trust me
uh this is a crazy this this is an
example of crazy um and
like crazy is so crazy
and
unaware of itself that it will actually
call in on a radio show
for the entire world to see the crazy so
let me just throw this up on the screen
because
there is a clip a video clip with audio
so
boom boom boom
there it is and let me just play this
back at slightly faster speed so we're
not sitting here for eight minutes
straight and here we go just just listen
to this
yeah uh well i didn't go there okay
why haven't you called her though
i didn't call her um well i didn't call
her because i have a girlfriend
hey let's welcome charlotte to ghosted
hello
hello
charlotte's energy is infectious and
awesome charlotte welcome to the show
we're so excited nutters are always
infectious and awesome aren't they let's
just listen ready to have you here
except for the fact that it's ghosted
which isn't great uh but yours is a bit
unique because you don't believe that
you were actually ghosted just yet
no not just yet
so tell us what happened what's this
deal with this guy liam
well
i've kind of fallen for somebody and i'm
pretty sure he feels the same
he's just kind of you know he's i feel
like he's playing hard to get okay but
you know i kind of like that game and i
i usually win
first thing she said there was i like
that game and i usually win
right narcissist this is you know this
is how they think this is how they
behave you know they think that they're
above everything so hard to get he's not
calling you back
all right i've played that game too hey
listen so so tell us about the story
with this guy liam
well his like he said his name's liam
and i met him on a work retreat last
week oh
yeah i mean he works in a different
office than i do so you know doesn't
really break that role
um so that was actually my first time
meeting him
okay um we just oh my gosh we clicked
instantly and we were basically
inseparable the whole time
i know
i know so that's why i say he didn't
really ghost me i mean i gave him my
number but he just hasn't used it yet
okay so now from you guys would be a
really cute way to start us so literally
this is just like you know when your
battery dies in the winter you're just
looking for a jump start
exactly okay all right all right
metaphor so why don't we put you on hold
and call him just we gotta play song
first cool good to go let's do it
so if you've missed everything with
charlotte charlotte has infectious
energy she meets this guy named liam and
it's not necessarily a ghost but this is
a guy charlotte gave her number two but
he hasn't used it yet do i have that
right charlotte that is right and where
did you meet
we met at a work retreat oh cool that's
always fun yeah and you know what
sometimes you got that like first off
it's a little bit like you're away from
home and that's fun and number two you
have like
your your job in common i think that's
cool
yes yes i mean he works at a different
office like i said but you know during
the retreat we just talked and talked
about we were just i mean we were
together the whole time it was awesome
earlier this week we had a love story
and i wonder if this is sprinkling of
another one two for two here okay so you
know what let's give liam a call you
ready to go
let's go let's go
hello
hi is this liam
hey yep
who's this liam it's adam wild and
jack's from 99.9 virgin radio good
morning
hey guys what's going on hi
what's what to do with you
uh
uh you know uh not much what what uh
what's going on with you guys
um we're actually just calling about i
don't know if we can't classify it as a
ghosting but we understand that there's
a phone number that you were given at a
work retreat and you have not used it
yet and i guess we're being super nosy
we want to know why
phone number huh um
who whose phone number is it charlotte
charlotte
uh
i'm sorry charlotte
that would be charlotte
charlotte
did charlotte from work the work retreat
yes oh charlotte yeah uh well i didn't
go through
okay
he he he doesn't even know who she is
when these people call her call him and
put him on the spot she's all we had a
connection you know it's gonna go
somewhere they call this guy out of the
blue and he's like i don't even
recognize the name right like you see
the disconnect with her reality versus
this guy's but it gets worse you called
her though
i didn't call her um well i didn't call
her because i have a girlfriend
um charlotte knows that i have
girlfriends i mean did she ask you to
call me hi is that how you got this
number uh hey liam me charlotte hi
liam let's just stop playing games okay
we had a real connection in muskoka and
i felt it we talked all night saturday
you can't tell me there wasn't anything
there
hey charlotte look
i thought that we already talked about
this i've got a girlfriend i have a
girlfriend you know this i think you're
great
but i'm committed to annie
oh annie you know what speaking of annie
you told me about annie and all the
issues you were having with her and it
really didn't sound like you were that
committed at that point liam
are you are you listening to the way
that she's speaking to him now
right disparaging you know
using that condescending tone monica
charlotte that is not what i told you i
was confiding about trying to be a
better partner for annie and i'm sorry
if you took it any other way
really
you could have pulled me but you know
listen lamb
i know what i felt in the lodge that
night and i know
i am sure that you felt it too i saw it
in your eyes
i look i get that you have us
girlfriends but you know
people come into your life for different
reasons okay all right all right
charlotte
you can have a good conversation with
somebody uh and and it not go anywhere
yeah but you didn't see how he was
looking at me i mean you're right the
moment i met him but i'm i am hearing
how he's talking to you now
yeah but he
you didn't see him then
i mean right but then the moment i met
him i knew he was supposed to be in my
life i mean we don't have to jump into
anything just yet liam i get that it
doesn't feel the same way and everything
but wow liam do you feel the same way do
you feel like first off do you feel like
you have mislead charlotte here because
i could understand if you from
charlotte's perspective if she felt one
way and you left her feeling that way
and you've now changed your mind you're
welcome to do that but you should give
her the heads up
no
i'm sorry uh annie is my girlfriend and
that is not gonna change
so i don't have anything to admit and
again like i'm really sorry if you took
it any other way charlotte but i'm well
there's there's nothing
changing in my room
okay okay you need to lead me on liam
way to lead me on go complain about your
girlfriend and all the problems you're
having with her and i'm sorry does that
make you feel good about yourself okay
all right all right okay so so here's
here's what we're not gonna do we're not
gonna get into the mud slinging here
um i think i think it's probably best
that we both go our separate ways here
we would all parties agree
yeah i'm going to go now okay you go you
go
for nothing that was a major waste of my
time liam he's just not the one
thanks for nothing that was a major
waste of my time like
dude's at a work retreat and
she's calling a radio station
to put a guy on the spot that's in a
relationship
to try to remove him from her so he can
get in on some of that
like
that's a level of crazy fellas you know
pay attention to that that's that's i
mean he should have given her the wrong
number to begin with
that would have solved the problem they
could have never called him in on the
radio show
exactly just to get her off his back but
that's a psychopath right there hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you